[Music]
imagine you're an interstellar traveler
what sorts of alien life might you find
out there in the universe it's
interesting to speculate on how life
might evolve in the depths of a planet
covered by oceans or the skies of a
world with an atmosphere teeming with
floating life perhaps one day humanity
will be able to set out into the
universe and document these unfamiliar
worlds firsthand this concept is
explored in great scientific detail in
the teeming universe an interstellar
field guide by speculative author and
artist christian klein the book which i
have a link to down below explores how
alien life might evolve on various types
of planets much different from our own
so for this entry into the archive we'll
be joining a scientific vessel on a
journey into the beyond and we'll
explore just some of the worlds that
klein covers in his field guide
several million light years from earth
the first fictional planet we're
touching down on doesn't look like much
this is planet meneer a world of ice and
rock with a diminished atmosphere and
high levels of ultraviolet radiation
stepping out onto the surface it seems
like there isn't any life here but
that's because to find life on meniere
you have to look under a microscope
that's right the first alien life we
found is a kind of bacteria it might
seem disappointing and there will be
much larger aliens to come later in this
entry but even discovering microscopic
life on an exoplanet would be a huge
moment in science and just because these
life forms look like earth
microorganisms to the untrained eye it
doesn't mean they're the same called
monerophiles by the artist he imagines
their unique purplish pink color helps
them reflect excess radiation and
because they contain hydrogen peroxide
within various organelles instead of
water they don't freeze while such a
mixture would be deadly to earth
bacteria minerophiles are protected from
the harsh effects by silicon in their
molecular structure so while the life on
the desolate meniere may be tiny it's
exceptionally resilient but the time has
come to leave this exoplanet and head to
a world where life gets a little bigger
at first glance our next planet ateria
appears far more earth-like with a
protective atmosphere in liquid oceans
eteria offers a much better opportunity
to find complex alien life and touching
down on the surface it's a beautiful
foggy day out of the mist rise grand
plant-like structures and the air is
filled with the buzzing of animals yet
we'll find ataria is much different from
earth in one critical way it seasons on
earth seasonal change happens gradually
due to earth's axial tilt with most
animals having numerous strategies to
adapt to the predictable changes but due
to a past asteroid impact aeteria has a
wildly elliptical orbit meaning it moves
close to the sun for some of its orbit
and far out into the cold of space for
the rest this means the seasons on
eteria are truly extreme and life on
this planet has had to get creative
beginning with plants we might spot
strungs which possess a bright red tint
to get the most out of the sun's
slightly dimmer light during winters
when the environment cools strung's
partially hollow bark retains insulating
air allowing for extra heat protection
but other organisms like the fissure
crame the first animal we've encountered
on our voyage have a different strategy
to survive the seasonal changes they
might look somewhat like insects but
fisher crames are far larger with a
wingspan of 4 feet or 1.2 meters and to
outsmart the cold these creatures simply
die after laying eggs which a new
generation emerges from when the
temperatures rise again to start the
cycle anew
another insect-like creature the tripper
hog has the more familiar strategy of
hibernating during the long winter with
their thick shells camouflaging them and
protecting them from harm another clever
solution ateria is a fascinating and
extreme world but we must look to the
horizon once again and see how much more
incredible alien life can get the next
stop on our journey is the massive
fictional planet called toriya the
brilliant blue of this planet comes from
the fact that 99 of its surface is
comprised of an incredible planet-wide
ocean and life in our own oceans can
already be so alien you can imagine
what's under the waves of these endless
waters the region closest to the surface
is called the pelagic zone and contains
entire ecosystems founded on towering
colonies of kelp-like plants
nicknamed heaven kelp these plants can
grow up to an astonishing 750 feet or
228 meters in length almost like
underwater trees among the leaves
aquatic life such as the fish-like
pelagonarians seek shelter and food some
fish on earth live in undersea forests
of kelp or seaweed for similar reasons
pelagonarians or pellegs for short are a
highly diverse group that have evolved
to fill all manner of underwater niches
the incredible diversity of the pelegs
makes the oceans of torreya a teeming
aquatic wilderness much like the richest
areas of earth's oceans the artist
imagines that one species of pellegs the
gallant gulls can even leave the water
altogether as they've evolved powered
flight due to their aquatic ancestry
however they still need to occasionally
dive back underwater to breathe but the
pelegs aren't the only life forms that
lurk below the waves further down in the
twilight of the bathypelagic zone you
can find various translucent or
bioluminescent species feeding on
floating pieces of organic matter or on
each other and it's here where the
largest organisms in the ocean dwell the
enum the most gigantic creatures we've
encountered on our journey so far
they're able to reach a staggering 250
feet or 72 meters in length due to the
vastness of the planet's oceans which
the anum navigate on an enormous
transparent sail curiously the anum are
comprised of vast colonies of
jellyfish-like invertebrates which work
together as a single giant life-form and
at the bottom of this planet-wide ocean
you can find the abyssopelagic zone
where ghostly pale grey species swim
through the dark in the absence of
sunlight many life forms in the abyss
survive off a chemical soup supplied by
hydrothermal vents an extreme form of
survival that also occurs in our own
oceans proving life can take hold almost
anywhere and the next imaginary planet
on our interstellar journey is no
exception at 64 percent of earth's mass
eulene is the smallest planet we visited
yet its gravity is therefore so low it's
on the very edge of the minimum for
planetary habitability which has had a
fascinating effect on the planet's
native life much of ulean's surface is
locked in permanent ice caps as the low
gravity has resulted in a thin
atmosphere that retains little heat
while some forms of life venture into
these frozen wastes most of the planet's
organisms live on the warmer equatorial
tundra here for the first time in our
interstellar voyage we can spot trees
which are quite similar to those on
earth similar doesn't mean the same
however and upon closer inspection of
their leaves you can spot some key
differences due to a higher presence of
blue visible light on you lean leaves
have evolved to use not chlorophyll but
the yellow pigment xanaphil for
photosynthesis and above the yellow
foliage you can spot the magnificent
cleary flying animals similar to birds
or pterosaurs these low gravity flyers
have wingspans of nearly 40 feet or 12
meters which they use to soar on
mountain thermals that help them achieve
liftoff despite the thin atmosphere
after mating cleary build nests in the
branches of yulin's trees raising their
young in pairs like many species of
birds and their newborn babies are
called clerits which is one of my
favorite details cleary typically feed
on animals like the cobble back trait an
aquatic creature that gets its name from
a pattern of stone-colored markings that
help camouflage it from predators
gliding overhead to lay their eggs the
cobbleback trait like many freshwater
earth fish must make a trying voyage
upstream to the frigid regions where
predators are scarce one creature that
doesn't have to worry about predators
however is the armored sisopi low
gravity grazers that can grow up to 20
feet or 6 meters in length from the edge
of the tundra to the continental deserts
you can find these shaggy giants which
move in great herds not unlike earth
bison and as the sun sets on you lean
many plants let off a brilliant glow to
attract pollinating species it's a
dazzling display but the time has come
to continue our expedition and the next
imagined world is perhaps the most
extreme so far borwold is a planet that
closely orbits a red dwarf star only 20
percent the size of our sun and far
cooler borold is also tidally locked
with one side of the planet perpetually
facing the sun in an endless day and the
other trapped in an endless night yet
despite the harshness of borrowed there
is life upon this rock in the less
extreme twilight region between the dark
and light sections of the planet you can
find the borrowed stars the largest
animals on this planet's surface these
creatures can grow up to 30 feet or 9
meters long since the gravity on this
planet is almost three times that of
earth these stars creep slowly across
the ground almost like giant terrestrial
starfish the real challenge for these
stars however is food and water unable
to hunt due to their top speed being one
mile or 1.6 kilometers per hour borrowed
stars simply crawl over anything edible
and crush it under their body and when
they find water these unusual creatures
can drink hundreds of gallons at a time
borrowed stars aren't alone on this rock
however there are also plants just not
plants as we know them these are the
valleyan azure which look like jagged
tall stones but are actually cone-shaped
photosynthetic life forms most analogous
to earth trees their design helps
protect them from the planet's brutal
winds which are the result of the
extreme temperature gradients produced
by the planet's tidal lock our final
borrowed organism however can take
advantage of these perpetual winds to
achieve liftoff you might not expect
flying creatures on a world with such
crushing gravity but borrowed kites or
scavengers that let these currents carry
them to their next meal unique certainly
but even more fantastical life forms
might be waiting on the final stop of
our journey
the last fictional planet we'll be
visiting is also the largest of them all
a world somewhere between a terrestrial
planet and a gas giant her kellion has a
thick atmosphere divided into layered
ecosystems almost like an aerial ocean
and it is in this atmosphere where we'll
find some of the most awe-inspiring life
in all the cosmos in the stratosphere
balloon-like animals float on sacks of
internal hydrogen steering themselves
through the air on specialized fins many
of these animals feed on green clouds of
aerial foliage groups of small floating
plants held aloft by the wind which
contribute to the high oxygen levels in
herkelion's atmosphere in feeding on the
herbivores are spell-does airborne
predators which despite being twice as
long as a school bus are quite agile
spildos lack jaws but their gaping
mouths are filled with teeth so to hunt
they simply ram into their prey but the
spill does aren't the true titans of
these skies wounds are the largest
animal we've found on our expedition at
over three times the size of a blue
whale indeed oons are more than just
singular life forms and incorporate
dozens of symbiotic species into their
bodies unmites are among the most
important as they act like the colony's
guardians while normally docile they
become fierce protectors when the unit
they call home is threatened sometimes
however innune passes away and falls
through the atmosphere to her kellyanne
surface in a striking event known as a
noon fall below the calmer upper
atmosphere the surface of herkelion is a
volcanic stormy wasteland and one of the
most extreme regions glimpsed so far yet
even here there is life like the tiny
praguler worms which you can spot
illuminating the dark with their
bioluminescent displays these humble
organisms prove once and for all that
life can take advantage of even the most
extreme scenarios
although our journey through the cosmos
is over for now christian klein's book
the teeming universe contains many more
incredible speculative worlds and alien
creatures and i encourage you to check
out the link to it below i've also
included a link in the description to
astroviti a relatively new speculative
biology magazine that you can read
online for free the teaming universe was
recently featured there and they've got
a lot of other cool stuff too so i
wanted to spread the word to fans of the
genre and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious see you in the
next video
you